my name is Miroslav Volf and i teach
here at yale university I teach in the
Divinity School as well as this course
that is offered for the university as a
whole entitled faith and globalization
which I teach together with Tony Blair
and the professor Douglas ray from
School of Management my guest today is
muna abu suleiman muna abu Suleiman is
the executive director of the Prince
Alwaleed bin Talal foundation and the
leading media personality in the Middle
East she has served as co-host of one of
Middle East broadcasting company's most
popular social programs which reaches
worldwide audience by satellite miss Abu
Suleiman was named young global leader
by World Economic Forum in 2004 and she
also serves as lecture in American
literature at King Saud University in
Riyadh muna welcome it's great to have
you here you are a professional woman as
just I just read from your bio and
you're also a celebrity and you're a
Muslim woman who wears a headscarf some
people modern Westerners and I suppose
also traditional Muslims might think
that there is something contradictory in
Congress about this well yeah some
people might think it's very strange
that somebody who wears a headscarf
actually has a normal life and
unfortunately the media plays a little
bit of a role in showcasing how some
women who look like me are actually
under extreme poverty at the Islamic
world in general is huge and it has a
lot of poor countries in it a lot of the
developing countries are Muslim and
therefore the image that you get is of
somebody who's oppressed who is not
having access to information but I
assure you there are a lot of people who
look exactly like me to be like me and
are very professional so it might be
contradictory but it's very
but but headscarf correct me if I'm if
I'm mistaken traditionally has has been
or the veil has traditionally symbolized
an indicated kind of domestic sphere of
women is that would that be correct on
the vehicle system that's which we are
not part of hopefully anymore
no the headscarf symbolizes modesty it
symbolizes faith it symbolizes
somebody's commitment to living a
certain lifestyle that is making the
family the most important part of your
priorities it does not mean that you
stay at home it has meant a lot of
people lack of access like in Turkey if
you're the headscarf you were not able
to go to universities for some time and
in France you can't go to schooling even
if you were then it's coming so there
has been oppression associated with it
but it's actually coming from the
secularist or the Western point of view
rather from the eastern hmm so you're
pointing two perspectives on and debates
about headscarf in France on the one
hand Nicolas Sarkozy has made comments
about that in Turkey since I believe
it's 1983 or so it has been at the
center of the of the discussion of the
political life what why does it matter
so much it's a piece of art especially
on women over the world you know in our
parts of the world is this carved over
here is sexual ization you know the ads
and using women's bodies as you know to
ad sales so women's bodies for some
reason are like a hot issue either for
covering up or not covering up I mean
recently the the Miss Universe pageant I
think or Miss World pageant has now or
Miss California I'm sorry Miss
California pageant has said there's no
more swimsuit part of the competition
because they said this is actually
demeaning to women that judging yourself
on that basis is using that as a huge
part a component for the scoring of who
gets to be missed
California so women are just like a hot
rod for controversy
it just takes different shapes in
different places but so you don't think
for you this is not a some kind of a
political statement its politicized for
you it's an expression of your faith
exactly and so how is it related to two
faiths well if you wear the headscarf
you are saying that I believe what God
has said the way that the world should
work family should work is right that in
a way we believe that the most important
part of preservation is preserving the
family and making sure that it stays
intact as a unit and that we acknowledge
that men are visual and are attracted to
women through sexuality the overt sexual
ization so what you're doing is you're
limiting the overt sexual ization of a
woman to the private sphere where it
actually advances something advances
family making and and trying to help men
actually stay within that to limit
temptation that's a certain world point
of view which by way in the headscarf i
say i subscribe to it and so you don't
feel that that's oppressive to you as a
as a woman no more than having to work
out you know yoga and dieting so that i
can fit into a bikini in the summer and
look good and if i don't look good is
the same kind of oppression just
different forms really so in the sense
of what you're saying you know culture
has a and our belief systems have a
certain forms of expectations they're
embedded in the in the culture and if
one sees that as oppression one might as
well things see whole life is oppression
right exactly as the way that you
relationship I believe is important we
believe family is important we believe
that women when she loses the male in
her life especially if she has created
family with him is a weakness because
then she has to become a single mother
and usually even the monetary value goes
out with the male gets spent on his new
family
so therefore it
limits her financial access so there's a
lot of issues that actually impact a
woman and her family much more than the
male men then I can just leave so it's a
way to actually protect women's rights
and women's needs at a very important
part it's saying that keeping the family
intact is very important and that
through nature men get attracted to
women and how do you actually try to
make it in a way that helps both of them
stay in that marriage
some some some Western women you might
say well in a way women men are
attracted to women is a man's problem it
shouldn't be theirs they shouldn't
really imposition on women because of
particular bent in the behavior of men
let them deal with it
well yeah and that's why we have a lot
of divorces and we have a lot of you
know children here in the US and in the
Western world who are growing up in
single parenting so yeah if you decide
to subscribe to that point of view
you're saying I'm willing to live with
the consequences or that I don't see
them as grave enough and that's not the
world point of view that we subscribe to
that's interesting but you subscribe to
the Equality of men all right well so
it's just a difference and recognition
of that of the difference in a
particular form of cultural relations
between the two exactly I mean we
believe that women have two roles I mean
part of it is mother motherhood is a
role it is actually a duty and it's not
something that you you subscribe you
know you you give to somebody else
although now I've heard that there's all
these rooms in India being rented out or
even like because you don't want to ruin
your body so you can actually have
somebody else have the baby for you so
there's a business now that creates it
this is not something we would want in
our culture so there's equality in the
way that women have full access to
education full access to work it's just
that when she needs to be paying
attention to her family society and men
should support her not leave her so I
suppose many many women as well as men
in Western culture would think that kind
of rent a womb
for approach would be inherently
degrading to certainly those women whose
wounds are being being being rent rented
but you know sometimes it is through a
real reason or somebody cannot have a
child but I've seen some people say that
they don't want to be inconvenience for
nine months so it gets you know
something leads to something leads to
something and abuses occur so for us
family is basically the mother and the
father creating a family if they can or
if they're not they can't that's it
right you know we've talked now about
the headscarf issue as as kind of
Western almost Muslim community kind of
issue Western value I suppose I should
say or contemporary Western values
because when I was growing up it was
west I take it my nanny always wore a
headscarf
some kind of headscarf and all women all
women did that was it religious or was
it cultural it was partly cultural but
it was also it was also religious Oh on
Sundays when we were supposed to cover
their heads that's why they wore hats
but I never I mean I never researched it
to know what was the religious reason
behind that certainly certainly when I
was growing up in in Eastern Europe all
the babushkas that were those
headscarves they wore those cat's head
scarf because it was partly cultural but
also it was it was it comes from the
firmly religious tradition where women
ought to cover their in their heads it
says says that in in one of the texts of
the Apostle Paul really yes it's coming
hey you know that's news to me I'll be
using that line a lot more now okay I'll
show you where it is in the index in
this first Corinthians 11 and there were
big debates about whether whether that's
a culturally conditioned injunction
connected with a particular situation of
women at that time or there or whether
that's trans culturally binding let me
just explain something the problem is
that with the headscarf even within our
societies but it's become a symbol of
being
Servat 'iv or being good or evil so if
you wear the headscarf you're supposed
to be a good Muslim and if you don't
worried then you're not and I don't
believe in that
I believe that you know some people are
able to you know do certain things and
other people choose not to that doesn't
mean they're bad or good which
unfortunately that has become part of
the judgment process both in the east
and the West right so in the West if I
go and wear the headscarf
and you know public speaking events
people immediately say she's
conservative she's probably you know
doesn't believe in democracy they have
all these assumptions immediately just
because of the way that I look and I
think that needs to change
but it's interesting you mentioning
something that I want also to bring up
and that is that the debate about
headscarf is not simply West Muslim
world or Muslim kind of religious and
cultural perspectives but it's also
within the Muslim world itself is is
it's a hotly contested issue in a sense
well I mean let me know what I'm
referring to is is tantowi shaked and
tommy's that's not hey Jeff that's my
cup
that's the carpet that is different yeah
but but I I mean I I know that's that
there's a huge huge difference but but
it's it concerns the question of
covering so the debate women's covering
right and women's women's role are
contested also within Islam itself so
let's I think this is a very important
point to make specially to the audience
who may not be familiar with this is
that there's hijab which you cover the
hair and you wear modest clothing and
there's the niqab which you cover their
face and basically we're extremely loose
clothing and so that and personally I
don't believe in your club as part of
our religion period I'm there a lot of
text a lot of verses a lot of a hadith
that actually show that it's not some
people have and I think that's part of
whether you know patriarchal society did
oppress women have made it to seem a
little but that's a very small minority
by the way people who are in a club are
very small minority within Islam I will
leave in the cub as a personal choice I
don't believe it as a religious man
you know addict so therefore for me
clunk I was saying that nobody can wear
than a couple she did not say is wrong
what he said is that in the school that
were there were all girls hmm you
shouldn't wear than a cop because
there's no reason within to ask this
girl to take off before before he made
the pronouncement yes yes because she
was in an all-girls school at the way he
dealt with it I think was extremely
idiotic I'm sorry it's just I there's no
explanation for the way he dealt with it
he's not very well known for his fact
but the point that he was trying to make
and that got lost was that women among
themselves should not cover their faces
because that's even for the you know the
minority interpretation of new club
that's not allowed a female face is for
me is part of her identity and if you
cover it up then you know you lose your
identity and that's why I don't like it
but I'm not gonna say it to somebody
don't wear it so you wouldn't regulate
it at the state at a certain level you
you would argue for it on some cultural
personal moral or religious even grounds
I was at the state level and if I was
making decisions I would say it's a
personal choice but I'd also make sure
that everybody understands that is not
an Islamic edit because sometimes people
do get confused and that was the part of
a part of Tom Tommy's claim right it is
not an Islamic it's a cultural rather
than Islam perspective right now
obviously wearing hijab hasn't prevented
you from from doing extraordinary things
called an extraordinary but well well
you were named a young global leader by
the World Economic Forum so how does one
with the 1,200 other people by the way
over five years
well this world is a world is a large
place so how does one get to be you and
others young global leader well there
are different criteria basically you're
supposed to excel in something and
affect other people's lives so we have a
lot of young global leaders who are in
great doing great work in philanthropies
or in the final
system or in medicine or discovering
things or creating scholarship that is
pushing the edge
for example Daniel Shapiro was doing a
lot of work on negotiations so it's
different criteria but you're supposed
to excel at something and I think my
work in the media had pushed me in that
direction especially in the Arab world
and it was a recognition from the World
Economic Forum that my work matters and
that was it you know a great honor to
have been chosen some people think that
global institutions like World Economic
Forum and in general
top Excellence of power that
participating globalization processes
are very masculine that they're very
inhospitable hospitable to women I like
that they think it is no it is it is so
tell us how do you how do you how do you
experience it as as maybe non feminine
not just the masculine right so no I
mean if you look anywhere in the world
almost power makers are mostly men you
have a few exceptions here and there but
they're getting more women as they
actually go beyond feminism we go beyond
just the education and higher education
are actually pushing the limits of
reaching the top they haven't done it in
masses except when there's a quota
system but I think that within the next
50 years we're going to see a huge
influx of women reaching the top
decision-making positions and in large
numbers and I'm not sure if that's going
to change the way we run the world
though people are so similar about that
yeah people assume that women will
always spend more on health and
education because that's what they care
about and I'd love to believe that that
our nurturing nature will always lead us
into this yet at the same time I think
it's more about addressing our needs
I think it'll become instead of men
addressing their needs there'll be women
addressing what they think are their
needs do you think do you think also
has to do something with the styles of
leadership some people suggest you know
men are hierarchical top-down or
competitive more competitive women are
more networking and the stylized
multitask network we work in teams it's
all been proven in studies that most
women again there are always exceptions
but most women do work better in
collaborative environments but again
will the collaboration end up being
something that we think is different
from masculine result or not I think
that's going to have to wait a few years
and and might not the institutions and
the and the modern ways of communicating
and the tie kinds of kinds of projects
that are being undertaken in modern
institutions might it not be the day
themselves in a sense require more
collaborative ways of resolving problems
so that all top-down way it doesn't work
for men either
they still I know but men don't do
multitasking very well I mean I love
going to airports and seeing men with
children check through the airport and
women and the woman is pushing the cart
talking on the phone getting the kids
all around and it's not a lot of hassle
where is a man doing the same thing
getting like the baggage in making sure
all the tickets are in and all the kids
are in the same place it just seems
there's always a lot more commotion so
there's you know I I do it in airports
all over the world it's like my kind of
measuring of seeing how people deal with
different tasks at the same time and you
know I'm not going to say that mail way
of doing things is always wrong or the
female way of doing things always right
what I want to do is that it becomes
something that is more mainstream that
fits both because if you do it only the
female way you know losing half of the
population and some studies have shown
in education that one of the reasons men
are not doing so well in school anymore
is that they don't work so well in teams
they need a little bit of competition
they need a little bit of change so
there's all these schools now that are
separating kids in
six to eighth grade for science and math
so that they can deal more with learning
different learning styles and seeing if
they would actually do better or not so
I think what is the learning curve that
we're going through as the world trying
to figure out what is one way of moving
not feminine or masculine you are a
mother of two daughters and a
professional woman and often in the
lives of professional women and men who
take care of the children there's a
tension between home and and profession
and sometimes that's in the way of
achieving and certain goals and breaking
the glass ceiling
what was your experience first of all
there's a huge difference between doing
things in the east and doing things in
the West both culturally expectations
etc but also in the East where I come
from the family supports you there is a
huge network so if you do want to
actually achieve things I don't have to
worry about you know timing of
babysitters for example because my mom
you know if I end up built-in babysitter
both in Vegas that are exactly she'll
take care of the child for a couple of
more days if I have to travel and you
know and I don't pay anything for it so
you know I don't have to also be at a
financial disadvantage to be able to
create a setup that allows me to achieve
so that the family in the East if you do
want to achieve you'll find it you're
much more productive at the same time as
you said there is limits I have to make
choices how much of a mother do I want
to be though I think that being a mother
is just giving birth or being there for
the children when they need me in
building a very strong relationship so
that I can build their character and
actually be the most important anchor
for them and I believe that yes you do
make sacrifices and it might delay your
trajectory and also my but also the
skills that you learned from dealing
with children and the changes
multitasking they're multitaskers are
majorly but also you know patience and
learning how to actually juggle things
helps you later on and you
professional life especially the
patience part I think many don't have a
lot of patience some men I would have
found most men I've seen you know
usually men are you know if they work
through all the night to do projects I'm
like I'm sorry I need my eight hours of
sleep and they're my children and I
might do it for a very limited time but
I'm not willing to do it for you know
six years to get into a partnership my
children also need me we've been talking
so far mostly about professional women
majority of women in this world aren't
professional women they're at homes and
especially they're poor they once a seem
now I would make a claim they bear the
great brunt of the tough life that it
needs to lead as a poor person and often
having a kind of astray husband who
doesn't care so much about family and
the burden of living in patriarchal
oppressive setting of lack of care as
well as taking care of the children it's
a heavy toll at all on women exactly and
this is the whole point about Islam is
that realizing taking care of your
children whether you're poor or rich is
a huge amount of energy investment and
time and that therefore society and men
have to support you and that if you
don't create certain things or certain
expectations then what happens is that
men do stray and the society doesn't
support you because it's easier to
ignore you and you bear the brunt of it
so the whole point of trying to balance
that in Islam part of it is a job
part of it is seeing motherhood as a
huge contribution to society and you
know the world doesn't see motherhood as
a contribution to study they say they do
but it doesn't put any kind of numbers
on it so for example if you're a mother
who took care of your kids and
reasonably educated you could not get
back into the workforce
once you
leave your your kids grow up so what you
want to change that also a lot of things
that I would like to change one of them
is that how do we actually acknowledge
financially motherhood so that if you do
come after 20 years of raising your kids
but here at your multi skills a
multitasking skills looking at the
patient's looking at the management
looking at all these things that you've
actually done and had to do help you
maybe hand the professionalism of it but
then say you're not starting as an
intern you're not starting as a novice
you're starting at assistant manager and
therefore your salary will be this much
more rather than having her start from
zero at the age of 40 and saying you
know what all what you did to society
for the past 20 years raising great kids
that's zero for us and doesn't count in
a census work experience does not count
as work experience does not count in any
way whatsoever that's interesting
because the discussions that I've heard
in the West were how the hunters will
figure out maybe to remunerated say who
stay home so that they don't simply
financially behind but you're suggesting
well quite apart from remuneration it's
a question of ranch re-entry entry with
that workforce and there you need also
to have your experience count the only
renumeration that happens that when you
get a divorce if you if you are
stay-at-home mom the course actually
acknowledged your role in helping your
husband reach his because of taking care
of things so therefore you get 50% of
assets after you know while you were
married or something like that so that's
the only time but this idea has not
carried over I see that the work that
you do actually counts for something
other than in that instant
so you see also not just need for for
kind of structural changes and cultural
changes expectations and valorisation of
women's work as important you mentioned
Islam and as a religion it is important
especially for the empower women can you
say more about more about that for
example when we talk about the balance
of family the man is the one who has to
provide even if his wife has a lot of
money it's his duty to provide for the
family why so that she doesn't
feels she has to go up to work and is
seen as an equal contribution in
unfortunately some men do abuse that but
it is seen as an equal contribution for
what she's doing so therefore she
retains her financial she's not spending
her own money she retains her financial
independence and it is seen as this
obligation so therefore she can stay at
home if she wants to and take care of
the kids without feeling that she's
under stress so that's one instant of
the balance she gets credits in Islam
for mothering and he gets credit for
providing it is not seen as one is
better than the other but complementing
for the family if that's the question if
I understood it correctly right you know
I I'm thinking also of the discussions
and some of the sociological studies of
the influence of Pentecostalism
especially in Latin America on on the
kind of working poor and especially on
women talking about paradox of gender
where that type of Pentecostalism would
affirm the hierarchical relationships
not at the same time give voice to women
reign in the man domesticate in the
specimen yes they could make him
responsible as you were saying in Islam
for providing therefore society if he
doesn't provide society will ostracize
him there will be there's a huge cost to
not fulfilling what he needs to fulfill
right in this case it would be this
religious community which would say well
this is no way to be a tubal man you've
got to and the penalties for him I mean
he wouldn't be able to do other things
because people don't trust him is seen
as part of his character to be able to
do that yeah
it is unfortunate that you know women
because of physical disability pregnancy
and having children are for a
significant part of their life at a
weaker position than men we see it all
the time everywhere whether it's the
Western or Eastern world the poorest
people in any society are usually single
mothers it's not about race it's not
about education symposium is usually end
up being the poorest and they suffer the
most
and what kinds of things do you think
can be done in order to address that at
the global it's a global phenomenon a
global problem what do you think can be
done about well I think acknowledgement
of the different roles that people play
that acknowledgement of the economical
significance of motherhood not only in
actually your skill set for work but
also when you create a family that is
more balanced more happy more adjusted
what does that mean for society later on
and you know less cost of medical
interventions because children eat
better when you're you know it's home
cooked food rather than outside food
what is the benefit of people not having
psychological problems later on you know
and snapping so where's that real
benefit of having stable families on one
point but also the real economic value
of motherhood I think it needs to be
value so when you say I'm a mother it
doesn't you don't feel like you're
lesser person than somebody else as
professional which is what happens and
your comment takes us take us back to in
a sense where we started when we talked
about when you talked about a headscarf
importance of family importance of
mother motherhood and we've come full
circle back thank you very much for this
for this interview